for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so the last type of decay process will
be talking about as gamma decay so a
gamma particle or gamma photon is
represented like this it's got the Greek
letter gamma with the mass number of
zero an atomic number of zero sometimes
they don't even put the two zeros
because I mean they're kind of
irrelevant this thing has no mass has no
charge just a bunch of energy lots of
energy okay it's the highest and energy
of all the decay processes so what this
does is it will really it just releases
a bunch of energy and it often
accompanies or follows alpha or beta
decay now in this case I'm saying beta
decay as sort of a all encompassing ok
so imagine this imagine we have alpha
decay starting with polonium polonium
215 we got a DA there the Z there ok and
we get the alpha decay process once this
happens we've got we've got here we've
got an excited gotten excited led
nucleus it's excited hence hence these
stars ok so what happens is that excited
led nucleus needs to be excited it's
high in energy right it needs to be used
to stabilize so what it does is it just
releases some gamma particles this is
some gamma particles here alright and
I've only drew two but it could have
been more but it does this so as to
release energy and become more stable so
the general form here is really just
going from an excited state to or
relaxed state excited to stable high
energy too low energy so as far as what
happens to the AZ and n nothing happens
to them they're all they all say the
same same same same
so simply gamma decay allows unstable or
excited excited
high energy nuclei to release gamma
photons which I mean it releases energy
right to become more stable that's
really what's going on here that's
pretty much it also just to add on to
this a little bit a positron positron
here and an electron right or a negatron
if we want to think about it as it being
an antiparticle negatron really like
saying that negatron anyway a positron
and a negatron can come together and
annihilate each other and release a
bunch of energy as to gamma gamma
particles so yeah that's just a little
extra tidbit there this is the general
form notice I kept it going from an ex
to an ex because the identity of the
nucleus has not changed so I hope that
video was helpful and wrapping up the
different types of decay next video will
be a summary of all the different types
of the case you can kind of look at it
all as one big picture hope that video
is helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying